let's try to understand why the rich are
rich the poor poor and the middle class
well middle class as explained by Robert
Kiyosaki in his book Rich Dad Poor Dad
now this book is the story of Robert
Kiyosaki's life in some ways because he
talks about the two most influential
figures in his life his poor dad who is
his biological father a highly
intelligent educated man who has a PhD
and has a well-paying job but struggled
financially throughout his life on the
other hand was his rich dad who was his
friend's father and he had only eighth
grade education but he went on to become
one of the richest men in Hawaii so
let's try to understand how did these
two dads how did these two guys do what
they did and we'll dive into the three
most important lessons learned from his
poor dad Anna's from mr. H tan but
before we do that let's talk a little
bit about financial statements because
most people understand the difference
between income and expense it's very
straightforward but they do not
understand the difference between assets
and liabilities now assets are something
that works for you and generate income
for you even when you are not working
for example a cash flow positive real
estate investment that produces $1,000 a
month of income is assets a business
that produces income for you is an asset
on the other hand a liability is always
taking money out of your pocket even
when it is sitting idle when you're not
using it so for example a large house
apart for personal use for which you're
paying a lot of mortgage every day but
it's not really putting any money in
your pocket now that is a liability
a big luxury car you bought for your
personal use again that's liability it's
losing value every day so now that we
understand what assets and liabilities
are let's understand the three key most
important lessons that we've learned
from this book and the first lesson is
what we teach most kids when we start
off what kind of education to get and
the poor dad always told Robert well go
ahead and get the best possible
education so that you can get a great
job and he believed in conventional
education his Poor Dad was constantly
educating himself
teacher himself but he never really
learned about money and finances he was
an educated intelligent man he had a PhD
but he was ignorant when it came to
finances and how money worked on the
other hand his rich dad who had an
eighth grade education
he always said go and get the best
possible education so that you can start
your own business or buy a business and
give other people jobs a huge difference
in mindset his Poor Dad was saying go
get a job go get an education so you can
get a job while as rich dad was saying
go get the best education so you can
start a business or buy a business and
give other people jobs so his rich dad
believed in the kind of education where
he was constantly feeding his mind about
business about finances and there were
four key areas of financial education
that he always emphasized on which were
accounting investing markets and the
laws that surround financing and money
so really important lesson to understand
that instead of focusing our education
on the conventional education we need to
think about educating ourselves
financially educating ourselves with
accounting investing markets law and
everything else that goes around to
building a financial portfolio to
building a business the second lesson
one of the most important lessons is
once let's say you've gone to college
and you graduate from college what do
you do next
what kind of work should you do and
here's the key the rich don't work for
money
what do poor and middle-class people do
this is what his poor dad said go get a
degree and get a job his mantra was go
work for money for the rest of your life
and that's what poor and middle-class
people do they learn how to work for
money they work for others all their
lights the first person they work for is
their employer then they work for the
government because the government takes
taxes as soon as they receive an income
and then they work for the bank because
they buy a big house they have a big car
so they're paying mortgage they're
paying interest to the bank and so only
after they have paid they have worked
for the employer and the government and
the bank
do they really start to work for
themselves and then they wonder why
they're not rich and here's the
challenge
the for poor and middle-class people
it's fear and greed that run their lives
because they're stuck in a
trés they have this fear of not having
enough money so they keep on working
hard on their job and keep on trying to
make more and more money and then they
have this greed on the other hand of the
next paycheck of a higher paycheck so
they're constantly stuck between fear
and greed
that's what runs their lives they're
fearful of starting their own business
their own venture and that's where the
rich differ Rich Dad said the rich don't
work for money money works for us
so his mantra his rich dad's mantra was
the rich worked to acquire and improve
on their assets and these assets produce
income so rich dad was always acquiring
and growing his assets like businesses
and cashflow positive real estate and
stock and all that stuff and that's what
rich people do rich people own their
businesses and then they leverage
business structures corporation
structures and taxation to their
advantage and the third key lesson
really important lesson is once let's
say you have your education and you are
doing something you have a job or a
business how do you invest or spend your
money and the key the really important
key is to pay yourself first now let me
ask you a question you probably know a
lot of people who are making a lot of
money but are still broke in the sense
they have almost no real tangible assets
what happened what is the key to these
people going broke while some people who
are not even making as much money on
them they are rich well here is the key
the key is when do people pay themselves
when are you paying yourself now here's
what the poor people do they have income
coming in and then as soon as income
comes in it goes out into expenses they
never put the income into an asset they
never pay themselves they're ignorant
about how money works so the income
comes in and goes out as an expense and
they never get around to paying
themselves at all on the other hand the
middle class they start with a certain
amount of income they spend up that
income on liabilities and the
liabilities are just become expenses and
the money goes out of their expense
column and they have very limited assets
they have maybe retirement savings or
banks savings or some sort of housing
but that's about it they might have
higher-income but then they also have
higher liabilities which in the end keep
taking money out of their pockets so
these people the middle-class people are
paying themselves last the first thing
to do is pay their liabilities and
expenses and then they pay themselves
then they acquire limited assets and
they almost get no income from these
assets because these assets are very
limited or they are in retirement
savings or stuff like that
however the rich pay themselves first
now what that means is that as soon as
any income comes in the first invest a
portion of it into their assets their
money is employed right way the
remainder of their income is then used
for expenses and liabilities so while
the poor and the middle class prioritize
expenses and liabilities the rich
prioritize assets the rich ensure that
their expenses are much lower than their
income and that their liabilities are
much lower than their assets and paying
themselves first by investing in assets
is a big step in that direction so there
we have it the three most important
lessons from rich dot product now if you
would like to watch a lot more of such
book summaries of world's greatest books
for ambitious entrepreneurs come check
out our YouTube channel two thousand
books where we summarized the knowledge
from the world's greatest books for
ambitious entrepreneurs books like Think
and Grow Rich how to win friends and
influence people getting things done and
a lot more of all-time bestsellers